so I would like to now consider the
wheel that is rolling without slipping
and what I'd like to do is consider
let's draw the wheel rolling without
slipping and I'd like to consider the
contact point between the wheel and the
ground and I'd like to understand what
the velocity of that contact point is
and the result is surprising now we know
by our law of addition of velocities
let's call that the point P that the
velocity of P is the velocity of the
center of mass and that pointed this way
plus the velocity of the point P as seen
in the center-of-mass frame and in that
frame every single point on the rim was
just doing a circular motion so that
velocity is in the opposite direction
and the vector sum is the velocity of
this point P as seen in the ground frame
so we want to consider the magnitudes of
these two terms the velocity in the
center-of-mass frame of a point in the
rim has a magnitude equal to R Omega and
we said that the velocity of the center
of mass we call that the CM now the
rolling without slipping condition was
that these two magnitudes were equal
these CM equals R Omega or the velocity
of the point on the rim in the
center-of-mass frame is equal to the
center mass velocity of the wheel and
therefore the velocity P which is the
sum of these two vectors for the contact
point so that's when P is in contact
with the ground is equal to zero so what
we say is that the content
point is instantaneously at rest with
respect to the ground and that's what
really is the mystery of a wheel that's
rolling without slipping
if this contact point is the sum of
these two vectors and it's
instantaneously at rest with the ground
when the reel is rolling without
slipping the other points are certainly
not remember up here these two vectors
pointed in the same direction so that
vector has twice the magnitude of either
one
you